hahaha
on Friday night Israel was hit by
another terror attack one person was
killed and four wounded when a car drove
into them and the driver opened fire
near the beach in Tel Aviv the victims
were all tourists
the attacker was shot dead by police at
the scene
the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has ordered all Border Police
reservists to report for Duty
it was the second terror attack in a day
today two Israeli sisters were shot dead
in their car in the northern Jordan
Valley
diplomats in Jerusalem have confirmed
that they were British passport holders
the girl's mother was flown to hospital
in a serious condition and Israeli
security forces are hunting for the
gunman
the violence over the past few days has
been on multiple fronts
in the early hours of Friday morning
Israeli airstrikes hit Southern Lebanon
and the Gaza Strip the targets were
Hamas military installations Israel
blames Hamas for launching a volley of
missiles out of Lebanon on Thursday
it took Everyone by surprise and
threatened to be a major escalation but
it is calm again on Israel's northern
border for now
[Music]
um
in Jerusalem's old city has been a flash
point of violence in recent days but it
was quiet overnight and Friday prayers
passed without instant
[Music]
this was the iron doe missile defense
system close to the border with Gaza
today the Israeli military says it is
prepared for an escalation but doesn't
want one
the feeling is that Hamas doesn't want
an all-out war in Gaza right now either
are you conveying your position through
back channels to Hamas that you don't
want an escalation so there's always
back channels going on I can't talk
about them of course on record but
there's people talking to them there's
Legacy channels of messaging and I think
you can see from the actions and the
kind of Munitions that are being used
that both sides don't want this thing to
escalate
this evening Jerusalem is calm but tense
it wouldn't take much to spark more
violence
the religious holiday period was always
expected to be difficult and it is
proving to be so